There is no way for me to prepare you for
what I am about to tell you.
So I'm just going to go right into it.
At the start of the Corona virus pandemic,
Donald Trump's secretary of Health and Human
Services, Alex Azar, put a Labradoodle breeder
in charge of the day to day Corona virus response.
Let me say that again, Alex Azar Tast Brian
Harrison, whose experience was in breeding
dogs Labradoodles, specifically a crossbreed
between a Labrador retriever and a poodle
in charge of the day to day Corona virus response.
We, of course, now know that CDC and FDA,
both of which are overseen by HHS and Alexei's,
are they failed to come up with a good coronavirus
test for more than five weeks.
Other countries were rapidly developing effective
tests during that time.
HHS was slow to let the public know what was
going on.
HHS was slow to distribute PPE, including
masks that health care workers around the
country needed.
They were a disaster.
And now we've learned that Alex Azar selected
a former Labradoodle breeder, Brian Harrison,
to be in charge of a lot of that day to day
response.
This is beyond parody.
And it actually reminded me of, remember during
Hurricane Katrina and George W. Bush, the
head of FEMA, was a guy named Michael Brown
who completely bungled the response.
He had been commissioner of the judges and
stewards.
He was the judges and stewards commissioner
for the International Arabian Horse Association.
And while he was in that position, that organization
was the target of a bunch of different lawsuits
because of the things that Michael Brown did.
And Trump I'm sorry.
Bush made that guy head of FEMA.
And we saw how that worked out during Katrina.
That's what I was reminded of when I learned
that a former Labradoodle breeder was in charge
of the Corona virus response.
Now, I want to be really clear.
You've got concern trolls coming out of the
woodwork saying dog breeder is being used
as an insult.
This guy had also held positions in government.
If you look at his biography, it is very vague.
It shows nothing other than bouncing around
government agencies, which only raises more
questions about his competence.
And they don't even say he was a dog breeder.
His government bio says he ran a small business,
which suggests that they're not exactly keen
on playing up his Labradoodle credentials.
They're supposed to recruit experts.
That's the issue.
If you said you need a roofer and I say I've
got a guy who bred Labradoodles, you don't
hire that guy to fix your roof.
Right.
He could be a great labradoodle breeder.
But you don't hire him to fix your roof.
If you say we have a pandemic, we need somebody
to head up the response.
You don't hire a dog breeder.
You don't hire a roofer.
You don't hire an accountant, even if they
are competent in those fields.
It has nothing to do with making fun of dog
breeding.
It has everything to do with this administer.
Nation is constantly putting the wrong people
in the wrong posts while publicly saying we
did everything perfectly.
No one could have done anything better.
Brian Harrison has no BRACHT background in
public health and we're dealing with a public
health crisis.
Brian Harrison has no background in management
and he was supposed to manage the Corona virus
response.
Brian Harrison has no background in medicine
and we're dealing with a virus that causes
respiratory illness.
Just give me a break, guys.
You know, the trumpets will defend anything
and everything that this administration does.
And they are now defending this election.
Just chalk it up as a loss.
Take it as let's say, you know what?
They shouldn't have had a dual breeder running
Corona coronavirus response even for an hour.
Never mind a few days or however long it was.
You don't have
to defend this guy.